so Paula Deen has been handing out her
homemade goodies to the media backstage
every week after dancing with the stars
first it was brownies then cheese balls
and monday we got a pocketbook oh no yes
yep a purse full of follows pecans and
that purse has Paula's face on and paula
is this your secret are you weighing
down the other contestants with your
delicious food great time of day y'all
figured me out oh he's [ __ ] would
look I love that you have a bag full of
nutt our interview turned a little nuts
when we asked Paula a political question
Kanye West keeps saying he runs he's
gonna run for president would you guys
vote for Kanye Kanye way we would we
vote for Kanye West well he's coming
more time who that he is I mean I've
heard that name he is a rapper artist
married to Kim Kardashian oh it's two
kids no I would not well you heard it
here first but Paula does have her
reasons I don't think he has enough
political experience pecans Kanye oh we
love you no matter what you're talking
about Paula